[Música]
en esperanza
no espero ni los próximos minutos
la inconsciencia de lo que es la
resiliencia
es un término muy interesante
también lo personal ha cambiado mi forma
de ver la vida y espero que sea lo mismo
contigo
y proviene del latín
vale
qué quiere decir rebotar
la física a las ciencias sociales y la
psicología nos dan un término de lo que
es por ejemplo la psicología dice que es
como un resorte no se dobla y luego
regresa a su estado original
la física dice que es la capacidad que
tienen los ciclos mentales
de ser afectadas y luego regresar a su
estado original
en cuanto a las ciencias sociales nos
dicen que la resiliencia es una manera
en la que la persona que ha vivido
situaciones de riesgo muy elevadas
el resto de su vida son personas que se
desenvuelve en la parte del éxito y
también son felices
en pocas palabras de abrir la
resiliencia es la capacidad que tiene
ser humano para los problemas de las
adversidades
voy a salir adelante
el doblarse
y volverse a interesar
si nosotros hablamos de resiliencia
también estamos hablando del vínculo
reactivo
el vínculo afectivo es
yo tengo a otros personas que creen en
mí que me apoyan que me diste
esas personas utilizamos terceros
padres abuelos primos hermanos amigos
muchas veces gracias a esos terceros
nosotros logramos pararnos en la liga y
seguir adelante
el estilo platicar de dos historias muy
personales voy a abrir de las puertas
del corazón
con estas experiencias yo me puedo dar
cuenta
de que
es como si yo me sala
andar descalza por la vida
yo en un principio sentía que estaba
descansando a través de pactos sin que
las piedras tendrían las espinas de
energía
y me afectaba
pero conforme fue avanzando me di cuenta
de que no era tan malo pues nos parecía
que empecé a darnos cuenta
y así puede conocer el sentido de la
vida
puede sentir las plantas del agua
todo
la primera de tanta gente estilo en
platicar
hace varios años yo pasé por una etapa
de mi vida yo estuve un tiempo no salí
y la cámara
era muy triste para mí darme cuenta de
que estaba seco había puro tierra no
había plantas
uno de mis hermanos como la iniciativa
de empezar a traer de otro jardín
ramitas de plantas
las rayitas de los pasitos hacia olvidos
la tira poniendo las pilas regando y
pongo ruegos el jardín dejaba salir la
cámara comenzó a florecer
pasa un poco más de tiempo empezaron a
es temporada de lluvia y el jardín se
escuchó hermoso los árboles empezaron a
crecer empezaron a sacar sus flores más
adelante los frutos y fue una
experiencia hermosa porque yo les tomaba
por la ventana y me sentía con el guía
resistía viva y optimista lista para
expresar la vida
hasta la fecha
hermosa
es una historia en la que puedo decir
que gracias a los terceros las 10 esas
personas que hacen nuestro vínculo
afectivo
nosotros podemos salir adelante en la
vida
en una historia que te quiero platicar
voy a hacer un año el año pasado yo me
estaba preparando para correr mi primer
medio maratón
un medio maratón 10.000 km
pero en términos durísimos porque me
tenían que alimentarnos perdí me tienes
que preparar sus exámenes me desgarraba
su me dolía todo el cuerpo las piernas
las rodillas
y no solamente fue esa pesadez de
incluso tener que correr unos 16 18
kilómetros sino también el tener que
decir no a muchos de los planes que
tenían mis amigas con mis amigos
cumpleaños
tengo esta realidad objetivo
tengo mi entrenamiento perdón pero no
puedo
dos días antes de ser el evento
tengo que comer ni 18 km de estar
preparando
era un día general de la noche porque
estaba oscuro
[Música]
trayectoria
en dos opciones la primera es pasar por
un lugar donde la bebida estaba lleno de
puntos
para el segundo paso por el otro lado es
un lugar donde casi no se ve nada hay
como unas cerca hay como una camioneta
no sé que puede haber ahí dije bueno me
visto a los coches y de paso
la segunda opción
al momento de pasar el perro yo me
asustó pero sigo corriendo siempre
duerme yo grito y no me detengo le
faltando a leer como 16 kilómetros 16
kilómetros en los que yo lloraba por
impotencia porque decía adiós es que se
me están poniendo muchas cosas de mi
vida como para dicho el logre ese
objetivo que tanto alguien lo que tanto
me ha costado
yo sentía como la victoria por mi pierna
llegué a mi casa me encontré a mi papá y
le dije 'vamos las competencias porque
me acaba de morder
llegamos competencia en el hospital me
siento
luego me llama la enfermera para mi
nombre me dice pase
al momento de intentar me doy cuenta de
que mi pierna derecha no reaccionaba
mi pierna arriba
como un ataque de risa nervioso yo
intento caminar me cuesta mucho
llega el día de la carrera en el maratón
y me doy cuenta
como los dos kilómetros termina sentir
mal empieza a doler de estómago
dice bueno en forma
de hecho la ciudad
conforme iban pasando los metros me
empezaba a sentir peor yo le pedía a
dios que me permitieran de verdad que me
dejara terminar esa carrera porque yo
había luchado muy duro
al estar en la meta
faltaban dos kilómetros para terminarla
y en eso me tropiezo me raspo toda me
caigo me levanto y digo no es posible
la mordida del perro es el dolor del
intento de talla de es como algo luego
me cargo total que terminó en la carrera
no me sentí muy feliz al terminarla
no fue la mejor carrera de mi vida
porque a lo largo de mi vida he corrido
varias
fue la peor
la más dolorosa físicamente hablando
pero ha sido la carrera que más me dice
nada de esa carrera yo me di cuenta
de que a pesar del dolor interior que no
puede llegar a sentir como seres humanos
puedes llegar a la meta puedes llegar a
la verdad
de la preparatoria de este libro
el hombre en busca de sentido de víctor
frank es un libro que me encanta y es
para pensar ha sido visto porque me
enseñaron lo que es el verdadero valor
del sufrimiento
luego a platicar que yo tuve una maestra
en mi vida de manera positiva
y ella no inicial puede ser extendida
entre otras varias opciones
este libro es negro
y yo en los campos de concentración
el vídeo todo esto él sabe lo que es
vivir
apoyos de estándares de día al terrible
en un momento
50 con sus compañeros que han perdido la
esperanza de vida
transcendió que han perdido esa libertad
incluso esa libertad de la que él habla
que nunca se puede
muchos de sus compañeros se iban a las
cercas para despreocuparse y de esta
manera que esta vida
él fue liberado
y cuando sale se da cuenta de irlanda
estaba su familia ya no estaba acá para
internet le habían perdido todo
pero aún así decide ser siguiente él
junto a la nueva tabla él tiene su
consultorio y empieza a tener sus
propios posibles
muchos de estos pacientes llegamos con
el oficial en problemas con la esposa
con el esposo con los hijos etcétera
etcétera etcétera
y dictó el gran de fascinar preventa
poderosa
i
[Música]
a mí me impresionante como un hombre que
estuvo en el campo de concentración
[Música]
pueden olvidar de salir al váter
es una historia
yo soy en la paulina de la carne
[Aplausos]
[Música]